rose if i only had a heart
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where hopefully you all
have hearts
unlike the poor tin man from the wizard
of oz
but speaking of wizards we're going to
be talking about some spellbinding
science in this video that will surely
get your blood pumping
partial reprogramming of the heart or as
the researchers call it reversible
reprogramming of cardiomyocytes to where
fetal states drives heart regeneration
and mice
cool
so the heart of the study begins with
well
the heart
that good old important organ that pumps
blood around the body as part of the
circulatory system to deliver oxygen and
nutrients and remove waste products
and it keeps on pumping without us even
thinking about it
unfortunately though the heart is still
prone to damage
especially for example from heart
attacks which reduces the functional
capabilities of the heart
not so good
but do we need to worry can the damage
be fixed
well to repair damage in the body we
have stem cells
stem cells are cells that look like
stems
i'm jaking stem cells are cells that
have the potential to both divide
continuously
but can also differentiate into
specialized cells
a specialized cell in this case being a
heart cell or cardiomyocyte the more
fancy name
for example you can find stem cells in
the intestine to replace cells lost in
your gastrointestinal tract
and skin stem cells that are constantly
replacing skin cells lost at the surface
the heart however greatly loses its
ability to repair tissue damage shortly
after birth
now this could be the reason why we
don't seem to see tumor formation in the
heart
but since the cardiomyocytes can't be
efficiently replaced
instead the damage is patched up with
the fibrotic scar
and this scar tissue reduces the
functional capabilities of the heart
so the ideal solution would be to
replace these cardiomyocytes or to form
new ones
but how
well this nicely leads on to the huge
topic of cellular reprogramming
cellular reprogramming is all about well
reprogramming cells
okay well if you must know it refers to
the process of reversing a cell's
identity
so
like a skin cell has the identity of a
skin cell it does what skin cells do
and so converting the skin cell to
something different would change the
identity of the cell and see another way
of thinking about it is you reprogram
that cell
and what has been shown now in numerous
studies is that the identity of a cell
can actually be erased
for example the noble prize winning work
by shinya yamanaka showed that
fibroblast cells could be reprogrammed
to become pluripotent stem cells
so going from a specialized cell to a
stem cell
and this happened when the cells were
given four factors
oct4
sucks ii
cmic and klf4
these are more commonly referred to as
the yamanaka factors or oskm as i may
refer to from now on
another phrase i will probably use in
this video is the differentiate
the opposite of differentiation when you
go from a stem cell to a specialized
cell type so d differentiation is the
reference of this process
although here they suggest that the
differentiation is more like partial
reprogramming
the cardiomyocytes can acquire the
ability to replicate like a stem cell
and like cardiomyocytes in fetal hearts
but they haven't completely lost all of
their differentiated features
as cardiac cells possess special
features and have a certain structure
that enable them to perform as cardiac
cells
and get your heart contracting
but this structure is not suitable for a
cell to divide which is why you need
this the differentiation process
to enable the cardiomyocytes to
replicate and to potentially repair the
tissue
so would it be possible therefore to
regenerate the heart could these
yamanaka factors be used to replace or
reform new cardiomyocytes
well this nicely leads us back to this
recent research paper that tried to
further explore this
so what they needed to achieve was to
get these heart cells these
cardiomyocytes to replicate by entering
mitosis
due to much published data so far on the
yamanaka factors
this seemed like a logical approach to
follow
though they were also interested in
testing whether reprogramming would work
without semic since this factor is a
cancer oncogene in other words in some
cancers this protein is overactive
so this would just leave osk
and before going straight to infivo with
the mice they first tested whether they
could get cell culture dishes of the
cardiomyocytes to grow
however neither micolone nor osk was
able to coerce these cardiomyocytes to
replicate
so they had to stick with oskm
but there are other tricks that they can
use to mitigate against the potential
tumorogenic effects of cmic
one is controlling timing of the
expression of these factors i.e when
they get activated and for how long or
maybe that's already two things and then
thirdly they can control the dosage how
much semic is going to be expressed so
whether it's a little amount or loads of
it or somewhere in the middle
so how do they actually test all of this
well they use a genetic mouse model that
only expressed these factors in
cardiomyocytes when they were given
doxycycline so it was an inducible
system and so because they could induce
it with this drug they could time when
these factors were activated in the mice
so firstly they adjusted this in normal
mice and six days with doxycycline
showed signs of de-differentiation such
as the presence of smooth muscle actin
suggesting that the expression of these
factors were having an impact
however prolonged exposure shows more
complete reprogramming showing neoplasms
cancerous growths after 21 days of
expression
and these graves could even be
maintained even if the mice stopped
receiving doxycycline
they also tested prolonged expression
but with a lower amount being expressed
so with a weaker continuous expression
however they still saw neoplasms by
seven weeks
so the data so far suggested that the
degree of cardiomyocyte
de-differentiation and proliferation
depended on when the expression occurred
and how much expression there was
so so far pretty much followed what we
thought you have to be careful regarding
how much of these factors are expressed
to get just the right amount of
reprogramming before a cell loses its
identity completely and goes out of
control
but does this partial reprogramming this
short-term expression have any benefits
for repairing the heart after damage
well as i mentioned they were studying
mice and to see how the oskm factors
could repair damage in their hearts well
they had to induce some damage
so they follow a protocol whereby they
can induce myocardial infarction in the
heart
and to test how the factors could help
with repair
they expressed the factors either six
days prior to the event
one day after the myocardial infarction
or six days after
and in each of these conditions they
gave the mice the doxycycline for six
days so to have that kind of partial
reprogramming
so effectively we have pre-treatment
acute treatment or therapeutic treatment
and in all cases they saw that the
amount of scar tissue was reduced when
there was expression in either of these
cases compared to the control
and they saw improved cardiac function
in the mice treated with doxycycline
before and during the myocardial
infarction
so it seemed at this point that either
the pre-treatment or the acute treatment
was best in terms of heart regeneration
as they point out
adults cardiomyocytes improve left
ventricle systolic function after
myocardial infarction particularly when
reprogramming is initiated as early as
possible
so it's important to point out that what
happened in this case was partial
reprogramming
which is the potentially safer
alternative to full cellular
reprogramming
as it enables the reversal of cellular
age of cells without them fully losing
their identity
now you might be thinking yamanaka
discovered the factors years ago why is
it taking so long to get to human
therapies why are we still looking at
mouse models well numerous reasons but
three main reasons
safety efficiency and effectiveness
as we've just seen in this research
paper it was only the short-term
application of the factors
a partial reprogramming approach that
was most effective and appeared the
safest for the mice that is no cancerous
graves
as you can see nicely summarized in this
figure continuous expression of the
yamanaka factors caused complete
de-differentiation and the development
of cancerous growths
and prolonged expression caused
irreversible d-differentiation such that
the cell's identity was erased and they
couldn't effectively mature into adult
cardiomyocytes that were needed for the
damage repair
it was only the short-term treatment
that caused the reversible d
differentiation that enabled the cells
to partially reprogram and enable the
adult cardiomyocytes to re-enter the
cell cycle and regenerate the cardiac
tissue
now many challenges lie ahead this was
done in mice
how long exposure would be safest and
most effective for humans
is there a way that this can be done
without cemic the fact that is commonly
overactive in cancer
what would be the best delivery of these
factors into human patients
obviously if both targeting and tight
dosage needs to be carefully assessed
this may pose many challenges for human
translation
as identification of molecular
thresholds that promote
de-differentiation but avoid a point of
no return will be critical to
engineering and safe therapy
but what is most exciting is that there
is evidently regenerative potential
and lastly it raises the question of
whether partial reprogramming could
cause the differentiation of other
post-mitotic cells such as maybe neurons
and so maybe in another video we can
help out the scarecrow with this brain
anyway um i hope you've enjoyed this
video leave a comment always keen to
hear your thoughts and if i like it i
may even give it a heart
anyway that's all for this video thank
you to my patreon supporters and thank
you for listening